Bien. Así que...
(Aplausos)
Ahora su tarea:
¿Cómo les hizo sentir estas formas de hablar?
la primera, ¿distanciados tal vez o simplemente confundidos?
¿De qué está hablando este tipo?
La otra, temerosos o simplemente aburridos?
Entonces, de nuevo, la pregunta que hice:
¿Cómo hacer para que la gente se comprometa
a resolver el calentamiento global?
¿Y por qué no funcionan estas dos formas de comunicación?
Ya ven, el mayor obstáculo para encarar los problemas del clima
se encuentra entre nuestros oídos.
Basado en una creciente literatura de psicología y ciencias sociales,
pasé años investigando las cinco defensas internas
que impiden que la gente se comprometa.
Cuando las personas escuchan noticias sobre el clima que les llega directamente,
la primera defensa aparece rápidamente:
distancia.
Cuando escuchamos sobre el clima,
escuchamos algo muy lejano en el espacio,
al pensar en hielo ártico, osos polares,
y muy lejos en el tiempo, en el 2100.
Es enorme y es lento: pensamos en gigatones y siglos.
Entonces no está aquí. No es ahora.
Como se percibe tan lejos de mí,
parece estar fuera de mi círculo de influencia,
así que me siento impotente al respecto.
No hay nada que pueda hacer.
En nuestra vida cotidiana,
la mayoría de nosotros preferimos pensar en cosas más cercanas,
como nuestros trabajos, nuestros hijos,
Cuantos "Me gusta" tenemos en Facebook.
Ahora, eso, eso es real.
La siguiente defensa es fatalidad.
El cambio climático generalmente se enmarca
como desastre inminente,
trayendo pérdidas, costo y sacrificio.
Eso nos hace ser temerosos.
Pero después de que el primer miedo desaparece,
mi cerebro quiere evitar pronto este tema por completo.
Después de 30 años de aterradoras comunicaciones sobre el cambio climático,
más del 80 % de los artículos de los medios aún usan encuadres de desastres,
pero la gente se habitúa a todo y luego,
se desensibiliza
por la saturación del uso excesivo.
Muchos de nosotros ahora sufrimos una especie de fatiga apocalíptica,
un adormecimiento por demasiada pornografía del colapso.
La tercera defensa es la disonancia.
Ahora, si lo que sabemos,
que el uso de combustibles fósiles contribuye al calentamiento global,
a contradicciones con lo que hacemos: conducir, volar, comer carne de res,
entonces activamos la llamada disonancia cognitiva.
Esto se percibe como una incomodidad interna.
Podemos sentirnos hipócritas.
Para deshacernos de esta incomodidad,
nuestro cerebro comienza a justificarse.
Así puedo decir, por ejemplo,
"Mi vecino, él tiene un auto mucho más grande que yo".
O bien, "Cambiar mi dieta no equivale a nada
si yo soy el único que lo hace".
O, podría incluso querer dudar de la ciencia climática en sí.
Podría decir: "Sabes, el clima siempre está cambiando".
Estas justificaciones nos hacen sentir mejor,
pero a expensas
de descartar lo que sabemos.
Por lo tanto, el comportamiento impulsa las actitudes.
Mi disonancia cognitiva personal aparece
cuando reconozco que he volado desde Oslo a Nueva York
y de vuelta a Oslo
para hablar sobre el clima.
(Risas)
Por 14 minutos.
Entonces eso me hace querer pasar a la negación.
(Risas)
Y, si nos mantenemos en silencio,
ignoramos o ridiculizamos hechos sobre alteraciones climáticas,
entonces podríamos encontrar refugio interior
de miedo y culpa.
La negación en realidad no proviene de la falta de inteligencia o conocimiento.
No, la negación es un estado mental
donde puedo ser consciente de algún conocimiento perturbador,
pero vivo y actúo como si no lo supiera.
Entonces podrías llamarlo una especie de doble vida,
sabiendo y sin saber,
y a menudo esto es reforzado por otros,
mi familia o comunidad,
acordando no plantear este tema complicado
Finalmente, identidad.
Activistas climáticos alarmados
exigen que el gobierno tome medidas,
ya sea con leyes o impuestos sobre el carbono.
Pero piensen lo que sucede
cuando las personas con valores conservadores, por ejemplo,
escuchan de un activista que el gobierno debería comprometerse aún más.
Particularmente en las democracias occidentales ricas,
entonces son menos propensos a creer los resultados de esa ciencia.
¿Cómo es eso?
Bueno, si tengo valores conservadores, por ejemplo,
probablemente prefiero autos grandes y un gobierno pequeño
más que autos pequeños con un gobierno grande.
Y si la ciencia del clima viene y dice
el gobierno debería comprometerse aún más,
entonces probablemente confiaré menos en esa ciencia.
De esta manera, la identidad cultural
comienza a anular los hechos.
Los valores se comen los hechos,
y mi identidad triunfa sobre la verdad en cualquier momento.
Tras reconocer cómo estos cinco mecanismos de defensa matan el compromiso,
¿cómo podemos superarlos?
Una nueva investigación muestra cómo podemos cambiar estas cinco defensas
en los criterios de éxito clave
para una comunicación climática más amigable con el cerebro.
Así que aquí es donde se vuelve realmente emocionante
y donde encontramos las cinco soluciones.
Las cinco soluciones basadas en evidencia para lo que funciona.
Primero, podemos intercambiar distancia por lo social.
Podemos hacer que el clima se perciba cerca, personal y urgente
trayéndolo a casa,
y podemos hacerlo difundiendo normas sociales
que son positivas para las soluciones.
Si creo en mis amigos o vecinos,
Chicos, harán algo, ¿sí?,
entonces yo también lo haré.
Podemos ver esto, por ejemplo, desde paneles solares en la azotea.
Se están propagando de vecino a vecino como un virus.
Es contagioso.
Este es el poder de peer-to-peer creando la nueva normalidad.
A continuación, podemos cambiar a ser solidario.
En lugar de escenarios que acaban mal
como desastres y costos,
podemos replantear el clima como salud humana,
por ejemplo, con deliciosas hamburguesas a base de vegetales,
son buenas para ti y para el clima.
También podemos replantear el clima como nuevas oportunidades tecnológicas,
sobre seguridad y sobre nuevos trabajos.
Los empleos solares, por ejemplo, están experimentando un crecimiento asombroso.
Acaban de pasar el número de los tres millones de empleos.
La psicología dice que para crear compromiso,
debemos presentar, en equilibrio,
tres marcos positivos o de apoyo
para cada amenaza climática ya mencionada.
Entonces podemos cambiar la disonancia
en acciones más simples.
Esto a menudo se llama impulso.
La idea es, mediante una mejor arquitectura de elección,
podemos tener las conductas amigables con el clima
predeterminado y conveniente.
Déjenme ilustrar esto. Tomemos los restos de comida.
El desperdicio de comida en los bufets disminuye,
si el plato o el tamaño de la caja se reduce un poco,
porque en el plato más pequeño se ve lleno
pero la caja grande parece medio vacía,
así que ponemos más.
Así los platos más pequeños marcan una diferencia en los restos de alimentos.
Y hay cientos de impulsos inteligentes como este.
La disonancia disminuye a medida que se impulsan más comportamientos.
Así podemos dar la vuelta a la negación
adaptando señales que visualicen nuestro progreso.
Podemos proporcionar comentarios motivadores
sobre qué bien lo hacemos con nuestra resolución de problemas.
Digamos que mejoró su huella de transporte
o se cortó el desperdicio de energía en sus edificios.
Y una aplicación que puede compartir este pozo se llama Ducky.
La idea es que cada uno registre sus acciones allí,
y luego cada uno pueda ver lo bien que lo hace su grupo, equipo o empresa,
y se obtienen señales en tiempo real.
Finalmente, identidad.
Podemos voltear la identidad con mejores historias.
Nuestro cerebro ama las historias.
Por eso, necesitamos mejores historias sobre a dónde queremos ir todos,
y necesitamos más historias de los héroes y heroínas
de toda índole que están haciendo un cambio real.
Estoy orgulloso de que mi ciudad natal Oslo
ahora se embarque en un audaz viaje de electrificación de todo el transporte,
ya sea en automóviles, bicicletas o autobuses.
Una de las personas que encabeza esto es Christina Bu.
Ella dirige desde hace años la asociación de vehículos eléctricos
y lucha todos los días.
También el Reino Unido, Francia, India y China han anunciado planes
para terminar las ventas de autos de combustibles fósiles.
Ahora eso es masivo.
Y en Oslo, podemos ver cómo propietarios entusiastas de vehículos eléctricos
cuentan sus historias eléctricas a amigos y vecinos
y los convencen.
Así damos un giro completo de la historia a la vida social.
Así que miles de comunicadores climáticos
están empezando ahora a usar estas soluciones
por todo el mundo.
Sin embargo, está claro que las soluciones individuales
no son suficientes para resolver el clima,
pero construyen un soporte ascendente más fuerte
para políticas y soluciones que sí pueden.
Por eso involucrar a la gente es tan crucial.
Empecé esta charla
probando dos formas de comunicar el clima con Uds.
Hay otra manera, también,
que me gustaría compartir con Uds.
Comienza con reinventar el clima en sí mismo
como el aire viviente.
El clima no es realmente algo abstracto y distante
muy lejos de nosotros.
Es este aire que nos rodea.
Se puede sentir este aire en esta sala también,
el aire que se mueve ahora en la nariz.
Este aire es la piel de nuestra Tierra.
Es increíblemente delgado,
comparado con el tamaño de la Tierra y el cosmos del que nos protege,
mucho más delgado que la piel de una manzana
en comparación con su diámetro.
Puede parecer infinito cuando miramos hacia arriba,
pero el aire hermoso y respirable tiene de 8 a 11 km de espesor,
un frágil envoltorio alrededor de una bola masiva.
Dentro de esta piel,
todos estamos estrechamente conectados.
El aire de la respiración que Uds. acaban de tomar
contenía alrededor de 400 000 de los mismos átomos de argón
que Gandhi respiró durante su vida.
Dentro de esta película delgada, fluctuante e inestable,
toda la vida se nutre, protege y sostiene.
Aísla y regula las temperaturas
en un rango perfecto para el agua y la vida tal como la conocemos,
y para mediar entre el océano azul y la eternidad negra,
las nubes llevan miles de millones de toneladas de agua
necesaria para los suelos.
El aire llena los ríos,
agita las aguas,
riega los bosques.
Con el extrañamiento global ante el clima,
hay buenas razones para sentir miedo y desesperación,
sin embargo, podemos entristecernos por el lamentable estado y las pérdidas de hoy
para luego mirar hacia el futuro con ojos sobrios y determinación.
La nueva psicología de la acción climática
radica en alejarse, no de la ciencia,
sino de las muletas de abstracciones y fatalidad,
para luego elegir contar las nuevas historias.
Estas son las historias
de cómo logramos la reducción, la reversión del calentamiento global.
Estas son las historias de los pasos que
pueblos, ciudades, empresas
y organismos públicos
toman para cuidar el aire
a pesar de los fuertes vientos en contra.
Estas son las historias de los pasos que damos
porque cimientan lo que somos como humanos:
terrícolas dentro de este aire viviente.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)